this is a production of Cornell
University
[Music]
congratulations to the class of 2020
unfortunately we did have not yet had
our 2020 commencement commencement is my
favorite activity of the year
to celebrate all of your accomplishments
but once commencement is set for 2020 we
look forward to welcoming both you and
your families back to campus well this
sure didn't end the way any of us
planned but we want you to know how
extremely proud we are here particularly
because you've persevered through these
last few months of our keyboard if you
stare in Ithaca you experienced snow in
May a few times these are left Ithaca
you probably did so with little time to
say goodbye to friends or professors and
all of you experienced the challenges
and joys of remote teaching none of what
has happened is taken away from the hard
work you've done from organic chemistry
to statistics to the outstanding job
each of you did doing your presentations
and the Senior Seminar in between we
shared Mills went on field trips
together with some of us travel together
to distant lands we hope your Cornell
experience has been special and that you
graduate with the knowledge skills
networks and confidence to be successful
in whatever path you take you're one
step closer to becoming our professional
colleagues we would be delighted hear
from you no matter how many years after
you graduate you have experienced one of
the most unusual semesters that anyone
could have imagined and you've done it
with grace and resilience I hope that
this sense of persistence that has
gotten you through this semester and
your time at Cornell carries you through
this summer and beyond best wishes for a
joyous future I just wanted to take this
opportunity to congratulate all of you
on your amazing achievements while at
Cornell and certainly wishing you the
very best as you move into the next
chapter of your personal and academic
life and certainly please stay in touch
with all of our faculty I know we're
always interested to know the great
things that you all achieve
in the coming years congratulations you
did it everyone got together and made it
happen
and you leave here with new friends and
colleagues and also a thorough knowledge
of the understanding of science that
Sciences it isn't a bunch of facts
science is a process it's a way of
knowing about the world the Eureka
moments are fantastic but it's really
about looking at that plant and saying
whoa that's really interesting that's
what drives science and it takes it a
collaboration of people to get this kind
of work done no one person knows
everything about anything and that's
what makes it so interesting so travel
the world no other people and cultures
collaborate widely I wish you love and
happiness and success and to always
cherish the diversity in this world a
class of 2020 just wanted to wish you
all the best as you go out into a world
that is so different than when you
started Cornell be safe be good to each
other and looking forward to hearing
what you're up to
we are extremely proud of you you really
made it it was so fantastic to have you
as a students during the last four years
we are sure that you will perform
greatly in any part that you decide to
take to all graduating seniors you made
it
congratulations just enjoy the plants
keep in touch hope to see you back at
Cornell sometime and I'm just here to
congratulate you on your graduation from
Cornell University I hope you enjoyed
your time with Cornell and I wish you
will I would have wished to congratulate
you in person and shake your hand and
wish you all the best for the future in
person but I'm very very proud of you
that you made it this far that you
completed this course even in these
extraordinary times surely memorable it
was a great pleasure to know you and
work with you I wish you all the best in
your future Kadima career and your
personal life be persistent aim high
never give up gratulations plant science
Jewett's of the class of 2020 job well
done and mission accomplished please
stay in touch we want to hear how
everyone's doing and once again
congratulations congratulations well
congratulations from the bottom of my
heart
congratulations congratulations 2020
plant science grads go on get out there
and get after it
plant sciences majors well done I wish
you great success in your future
mutilations to the entire class of 2020
you made congratulations Cheers
what's in this it's really God
congratulations congratulations
congratulations
[Music]
this has been a production of Cornell
University on the web at Cornell edu